novembre 2000 jamais une élection
présidentielle américaine n'avait créé
autant de suspense
à l'époque le républicain george w bush
et le démocrate al gore sont au coude à
coude dans les sondages
le 7 novembre jour de scrutin aucun des
deux candidats n'est déclaré vainqueur
s'ils sont forts ces américains
l'élection présidentielle de cette nuit
est un modèle de scénario hollywoodien
avec rebondissements coup de théâtre et
un suspense total
la faute à un état celui de la floride
un swing states est un pivot en français
ou le résultat est indécis jusqu'au bout
sur 5 million deux cent mille bulletins
dépouillés en floride
il y a vingt mille voix d'écart vingt
mille voix en faveur de georges bush
mais monsieur gore est en train de
revenir finalement bouche remporte la
floride et ses 25 grands électeurs mais
la joie est de courte durée chez les
républicains
en floride les résultats sont si serrés
que la loi oblige un nouveau décompte
à l'aide d'une machine au pays de
l'oncle sam le nom du prochain président
se fait attendre
en tant que citoyenne je voudrais savoir
qui sera mon prochain président or on ne
le saura peut-être même pas ce soir ou
dans dix jours
là encore bouche l'emportent mais le
camp démocrate ne s'arrête pas là ils
réclament un nouveau comptage dans trois
comtés de floride des partisans d'al
gore ou mal poinçonné leur bulletin
la présentation des candidats prêtait à
confusion
[Musique]
conséquence aux électeurs démocrates ont
voté par mégarde pour le candidat
ultraconservateur pas du canal avant de
se reprendre et de sélectionner al gore
les démocrates obtiennent que ces
bulletins invalidés soit finalement
prise en compte nous allons gagner car
l'injustice ne saurait l'emporté sur la
justice chez les républicains
ce nouveau décompte ne passe pas on a
tous reçu un exemplaire du bulletin de
vote avant les élections les
explications sont parfaitement claires
si vous avez fait une erreur vous pouvez
rendre votre bulletin et en prendre un
autre
alors ceux qui se sont trompés j'en suis
désolé pour eux mais leur vote compte ce
n'est pas une raison pour en voter un
recours en justice et même déposés par
les républicains
avant d'être rejeté le comptage manuel
se poursuit mais le 26 novembre 2001
coup de théâtre se produit je déclare le
gouverneur du texas george deubeuliou
gauche vainqueur des 25 grands électeurs
de l'état de floride
la secrétaire d'état de floride annonce
la victoire du candidat républicain et
sans attendre les résultats officiels
les démocrates comptent est de nouveau
recours sont déposés
encore une fois les américains se
réveille sans président
les gens ont voté on a déjà dépouillés
les bulletins on a compté une fois deux
fois
je pense que l'algue heures devrait
admettre sa défaite et que bush doit
devenir président finalement le 12
décembre 2000 plus d'un mois après le
scrutin
la cour suprême des etats-unis décident
de bloquer le recomptage manuel des voix
georges de bellio bouche devient
officiellement le 43e président des
états unis
[Musique]